hi there steve kaufman here um you know
i recently put up a video
and this is steve kaufman of course of
the linguist on language blog
founder of link and so forth
but i put up a video where i said the
only language we need is english
and i think most people understood that
i did that uh tongue-in-cheek
although i did get some reaction from
people who disagreed with that's the
title
of the video and didn't listen to the
video and in the video i explained how
my languages had been useful to me in my
business career
but but why do we learn languages
um
you know we often hear
that explanations like we should learn
uh you know english because it's the
international language of commerce
french because it's the language of
of uh diplomacy or in canada because
it's one of our official languages we
should learn french
we should learn chinese because all of
our kids are going to be doing business
in chinese in the future
guarantee them a job kind of thing
learn latin because it'll help you with
all your languages learn
german or greek because
it'll help you with medical terms and on
and on all of these so-called
utilitarian reasons for learning
languages
frankly i think those reasons are
basically not valid
with the possible exception of english
where english
is probably the most useful
language to learn because it has become
the dominant language of
international trade and science and and
that's not about to change in the near
term
however even for english the vast
majority of people who learn english
will not use it very much
in their job they won't use it to talk
to their neighbors if you live in japan
russia brazil
even germany
china
korea spain
indonesia i mean you don't have a daily
need to use english
a small number of people work for
companies that are involved in
international trade and they need
english
um
the other languages
it's basically not true that french is
the language of diplomacy that german
helps you in medical school and none of
that stuff is true
i did a bit of latin at school i was
basically i've forgotten it mostly and i
think was quite irrelevant in so far as
uh you know my language study is
concerned yeah one romance language
helps you with the next so if you learn
french that makes spanish easier makes
portuguese easier and so forth but latin
you don't need it some people say learn
esperanto because it's the language of
peace or something no if you're
interested in esperanto learn it but
don't don't apply to it some external
utilitarian motive i don't i don't
personally believe in all of that
the main reason to learn
languages
any foreign language is because it's
tremendously
personally rewarding
brings you pleasure and happiness
uh
not only does it bring you happiness it
also
gives other people happiness because
whereas english-speaking people are used
to the idea that people speak english
speak their language take it for granted
in fact most speakers of other languages
don't take it for granted and they're
typically quite pleased to hear you
speak their language it's a sign of
respect towards their language which is
most people basically appreciate that
and even in english if we hear someone
from another country who speaks english
very well we appreciate it we respect it
and we appreciate it it makes us feel
good but most of all
we ourselves feel good if we can speak
other languages and if i take as an
example
you know the languages that i've been
working on for the last 10 years
cantonese korean russian portuguese
and even where i've been refreshing my
italian or german or spanish
it's been largely out of personal
interest out of the pleasure that i
derive from those languages uh just the
last week i've been working on italian
so i went to el nadatore
dot com and downloaded
an audiobook of ulysses in italian
uh
marie color del vino
um
a wonderful story just wonderful and to
hear ulysses told in a slightly
simplified version i think it perhaps
might be intended for children or
teenagers but in italian
uh
and and you feel closer to the
mediterranean world because it's in
italian a wonderful experience um
you know it's be staying with il
naratore
moro silo which is mauricio
he has done a version of pinocchio
which you can buy on his site and at
which i have and which is
just phenomenal he
uh basically uh uh uses different voices
for the different
characters in the story and of course we
have the text at link so that i can also
read it there and save any words and
phrases that i need
i've also been reading a book in italian
by alberto moravia so i've had this
italian experience for a week and i've
improved my italian plus i've been just
enjoying it tremendously
and it doesn't matter what stage you're
at i enjoyed my russian right from the
very beginning
so to me therefore the reason to learn
languages is because it is very
enjoyable and that should be the
emphasis in schools
and if uh say in canada every english
canadian english-speaking canadian is
obliged to learn french and people
resent that in many cases aside from the
fact that it's taught in a very
uninteresting way
but let people have the choice nowadays
there's so many resources
available on the internet
uh
for any language basically
not only content at different levels but
explanations of grammar
dictionaries lots of things that can be
downloaded into an ipod what the
teachers need to do they don't need all
we don't need experts in these different
languages we need an expert in language
learning in the school to coordinate the
activities of learners to show them how
they can discover languages and have fun
and how they can use uh all of these
resources to succeed rather than having
them sit in class and and and you know
fight their way through some text that's
assigned to them in the languages
assigned to them it it all sort of
contributes to taking the fun out of
language learning so the conclusion is
why do we learn other languages because
it's tremendously enjoyable for
ourselves and for other people and what
better reason to do something than
because it's enjoyable and in fact i
just thought of something there it's
very similar to musical instruments
um a very small number of people learn
musical instruments because
they're going to be professional
performance that's a performers it's a
very small number the vast majority
learn musical instruments because it's
rewarding it's fun it's enjoyable it's
enjoyable for them as individuals and
it's durable enjoyable
hopefully for other people who are
listening or who are dancing or who are
singing along with the music so
we learn languages for the same reason
that we learn
to play musical instruments it's because
it's tremendously enjoyable thank you
very much for listening